what what friends did you meet that
you're to this day really close
everybody everybody i just mentioned
jane lynch and and um um
oh i i just saw rachel jackson a little
while ago um dave kechner um andy
richter um
mounty hutzel um oh my gosh there were
other ralph garman um i'm trying to
think some of the more
uh
yeah so that's cool yeah it was awesome
it was great yeah and the tour was like
i actually ended up touring it with for
a year we played the kennedy center for
seven weeks which was nuts i just kept
thinking they're gonna kick us out how
many people fit in the kennedy center uh
the room we were in was
uh 500 we were in the
maybe a 600
yeah or in the 60s do you get nervous to
this day when you're performing in front
of people whether it's live or whether
it's it depends what it is it depends
what it is what what does it make you
nervous what can you just do and you
don't get nervous and you just it's easy
well when jane lynch and i performed
together we've been doing uh
a live concert a comedy concert together
i know what you call it anti-cabaret act
we've been doing it for
like almost seven years now wow and
there's some like if we change things if
something's up like every once in a
while get a little bit nervous or part
of it not but not really i'm not
enormous you know you can just wing it
if you mess up or something and you mess
up right yeah and the the ball never
gets trapped i mean we're we're
perfectly imperfect it's you know i mean
jane is she's amazing she's incredible
do you ever lose your [ __ ] where you
can't stop laughing
uh
not not usually but every once in a
while i will laugh i mean not that
things don't i that i'm not enjoying
myself but right you know um
but uh everyone so you know one time i
was we were super tired and i i called
her joan instead of jane which is my mom
she was like what and i thought
that's your mom's name yeah and then i
yeah and then i said something i was
like
i was like we're not in high school
anymore this is in 1996. i was like i
don't what i don't know what that oh no
i said jane it's 1996 it's 2006. she's
like no it's not i don't i just made
stupid stupid whatever it doesn't make
it it doesn't translate but
have you ever missed smallville
[Music]
no really i mean it was a big part of my
life our life
okay i mean you ever feel like watching
an old episode and talking about stuff
you know
no no
never well would you would you do it for
me
no would you do it for the fans
[Music]
yeah why not
be fun
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast we've had some we had
some we have some good times but what
makes you nervous
um i think uh when something's new
like a new show yeah
yeah new material sometimes um
or sometimes when i have to sing where
it's just something that's pretty and
i'm i don't have the comedy
uh
to net to fall right yeah yeah you can't
yeah
that's something huh when you when you
have to be serious yeah is it hard for
you to be serious is it hard for you to
be in a moment
it's getting easier as i'm getting older
but i feel like i was so resistant for
years because i also feel like i didn't
really start singing as myself until i
started singing with jane
uh which is kind of crazy but because i
i when i did the lampshades i always i
was like i sing but i i wear a wig like
i'm playing a character you know i'm
making fun of singers
you